okay one more to talk about and this is
a guy who surprised me by showing up for
off-season workouts in dallas on monday
ezekiel elliott a guy that chris and i
both think should hold out a guy who's
been overlooked as the cowboys are
giving out second contracts a guy who
the cowboys very much may well chew up
and spit out and never pay a second
contract too chris do you agree with his
decision to show up for off-season
workouts yeah i i have no problem with
him uh showing up for off-season
workouts you know he's he's again the
guy who got suspended two seasons ago
you know he's probably still trying to
put his best foot forward he does love
football you know he wants to work out
be there be a part of his team i think
he can still get his message across to
the football team about wanting a new
deal by still being there and of course
really hey if he really wants to make a
a you know a mess of things or give the
cowboys a sign that he wants new money
at the end of the day you know holding
out a training camp is going to scare
the dallas cowboys a whole lot more than
anything with otas but you know to to to
a guy like ezekiel elliott too sometimes
i think for this players like take
advantage of this right now go work out
get in shape get ready be the best you
could be um but at the same time ezekiel
elliott has led football in rushing
attempts two out of the last three years
he has led the nfl in rushing yards two
of the last three years he catches the
ball out of the backfield a whole lot
and he plays a style of football that is
physical smash mouth i'm gonna knock
your head off type of ball
and that usually does not translate to
long long careers and because of that
yes i would have absolutely no problem
with ezekiel elliott after three years
of the nfl so far and leading the r
leading in the league in rushing twice
for him for asking for more money and
for him to be paid like that one of the
top running backs in football
yeah and and there really is that risk
it's gonna do to him what they did to
marco murray yeah and we don't know just
because they made him a top five pick
doesn't mean they didn't budget to have
five or six years of ezekiel and then
move on and do it all over again so i
would want that security you never know
what's going to happen with your career
when you are in those car crashes as you
say all the time and and i think ezekiel
elliott needs to be concerned that once
they start paying all these other guys
they're gonna look around and say you
know what we don't have enough money
left for ezekiel elliot let's just go
out and get a bunch of young cheap guys
and we'll staff the position that way so
now's the time to take a stand and chris
i talked about this
on radio in that first hour when you're
like in traffic and otherwise not paying
attention to the things i'm saying the
uh the reality is this just because you
show up for off season workouts doesn't
mean you show up for the start of
training camp what better way to stun
them right than to show up for the off
season program but then when it's time
for what really counts that's how you
get their attention and maybe they
exhale maybe they relax maybe they think
oh okay ezekiel elliott's on board
everything's fine and then all of a
sudden you don't show up for the start
of training camp that may be the moment
where they get the wake-up call and they
end up taking care of you yes definitely
now you did you not know i already said
that point did you know that i said the
same thing already i just wanted because
this i just want the listeners to know
see this is what happens i talk and make
a point mike texts and types on the
computer and then he comes up and makes
a point and wants to see me to react to
it and i have nothing to react to
because i already made the same point so
yes that would make a lot of news mike
you're right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports